Monday how was your weekend Brennan oh
you know it was nice I was in Seattle
Brown had some on the walls at the
parlor live that the old throwback
posters a Bryan Callen loved a I sent
them to you yeah old school did and what
was what was shocking as you go that was
ten years ago and I was like looked very
similar that was ten years I was ten
years ago they haven't updated the
posters really has like Amy Schumer on
there from 10 years ago heaven Hart from
like six years ago seven years ago it's
right like nothing's really updated it's
funny how though when you realize that
count Hart was doing the parlor live
seven years ago and now he's a little
bigger I don't know if you know this but
it'd be hard for him it did this tickets
go very fast if he sold if you went to
our live even for a whole weekend oh no
I'm saying that he posted some picture
he's in this amazing dapper dan Gucci
jacket shoutout to dapper dan but he's
in front of a crowd of 40,000 50,000
something like that
yeah that's what happens parla I loved
it over there man belt very nice blood
sugar low blood sugar right LOD not a
lot of aggression in the air which
everyone's white everyone in love that's
a lot of Chinese I didn't Bellevue a lot
of Chinese immigration a lot of white
though Bellevue is Microsoft you
understand Amazon yes so you actually
will find it maybe because if you're our
audience fighter and the kid but when I
would do Bellevue
most of the time it was a very very
mixed group of very intelligent and
nerdy Asian East Indian and white dudes
was one Callister even when we're out is
law a lot of white crowd hunched in yeah
a lot of white crowds and whites well no
no no done I'm sorry
don't make no mistake very white
possible right very well good coffee
good coffee was it cloudy uh no sunny
most the day I was actually considered a
really good weekend for Seattle yeah
chin talked me into korean Barbie for
the Korean barbeque for the first time
how was it will give me just okay that's
what I I was telling not because I'm a
huge fan of Korean barbecue it's amazing
but we don't look we're not supposed to
go to Seattle in that place I've never
heard of but but also I'm not racist
like that ya know but also let me ask
you out cream let's say you represent
all
barbecue you the President of the
Federation for Korean barbecue yeah so
you the state so I got to go to dinner
and then I have to cook my own food well
yeah okay listen no no no before it just
answer I got to cook my own me hold on
you see the meat and then we'll have a
grill for you and you're gonna do your
specification all because I can't order
from a steakhouse medium-rare and it
comes medium-rare but you might want to
add a little touch of medium-rare lose a
little more than a rare but I have to do
it all myself and monitor the goddamn
grill I'm trying to entertain my friend
I will admit that with clam barber who
they're a couple yeah a certain guys get
left behind okay they get forgotten
Buster got forgotten it starts to smoke
and you're like oh that poor guy that
guy's charcoal now and then they left me
in charge
I don't know I'm tossing all the meats
on and then Jays like we'll flip down
like hey man I don't wanna do this I'm a
chill yeah have that guy the waitress
[ __ ] do it I don't wanna do this it's
true there are two things that happen
one is don't take your ice off the meat
and that's hard to have a conversation
and to it it gets a little hot on your
face if you're not careful yeah it does
and here's the other thing old racist
chin over here racist chin well it's
just a rich sexist why should call gay
he goes I know dude we just have to
monitor the meat this whole goddamn time
it's exhausting I want to do this he
goes dude usually I come with chicks and
in the old tradition of Korea the women
has to deal with them well well well
that's why you see barbecue always
invite traditional Korean women or white
girls and like those are the rules bit
sir in light of current situations
either the dumb BMW mbm and I expect in
dudes to play go to Korean barbeque or
expectant women to be flipping the meat
cheese a corner chin though
Oh Oh while I was flipping it myself
we're all equal in that oh yeah well
Korean bastard it's [ __ ] up he has
gotten in he looked around us wish our
[ __ ] was around here that way yeah I'm
like you're making that child because I
wish I cut
this part so it chin we're in Seattle
dude hunts relax that's what he said
yeah he goes I wish I'd get it cut down
there to flip my bum so in my chin when
you don't know when you don't know T
like just I know dude that and you kept
your mouth away no dude I think I felt
think I felt
he's like oh we need some more pork and
concert flick the food
don't push it out of your the back here
throat I'm just gonna say is a little
overrated dude
alright that one cat is that true do you
have to flip the meat when you go with
your Korean friends or soon to be in a
sexist no usually I'm not Korean so I
don't know the rules about women I'm
just saying rules rules but also I don't
want somebody to [ __ ] up my me yeah
that's all cooking myself there you go
then why get a restaurant do you want me
to do pasta - there are Korean barbeque
restaurants that'll have the waiters do
it for it
all for you I hold on but they stay
there in front and do it they come back
and forth are you talking about Benihana
how dare you
that's very Hannes that's chap were they
cooking in front of me it's American you
know what
no I'm sorry that is American whose of a
huge huge admirer of Whitney's and
Korean culture
I apologize for like the movement thank
you sir
sir um but you've never heard that right
cat you never heard of women being in
charge of the meat meat you don't Korean
me I'm getting well I'm getting all hot
I love you me it's just a little
overrated and you know else dressed as
me the [ __ ] out the Fogo de Chao is the
green the red well I would say here's
the thing somebody said oh if I had like
thirty million dollars I would get a
chef no I get about you have people in
your house now
and then you have for me I'd be worried
about I'm you gotta take care of them
they have a bad day somebody's got a
cold their kid gets sick like I don't
want to deal with that man you have
staff your first ones never alone never
alone anyhow I'm not that wealth a post
mates every goddamn meal if I want s
days I get that free delivery woop woop
they come the house I want ice cream
they get it thirty minutes or less
I'm not scrooge mcduck I'm doing alright
black and post mates whatever I don't
deal with a stupid chef in my house a
lot of time I don't ask him how they're
doing it's funny how we've come to a
point where we when we want food we can
just push buttons whereas traditionally
when you wanted food you had you had to
hunt it yourself and brings me to a
topic I'd like to ask me what I learned
this weekend would you learn this
weekend Brendan I learned that you can
kill a wolf with an eagle yeah we mean
like take an eagle and RAM is stupid be
canoas face good question it's good
question
no what I mean is that I learned that
you can you can hunt a wolf a hundred
and thirty pound wolf with a 12 pound
eagle and that Eagle you can send it off
your arm you can send it out and kill a
full-grown wolf and then you can you can
skin that wolf and where it's coat yeah
so that's right let me where were you
this weekend I was in Utah yes I'll take
you let me just ask him sure were you
hanging out with an Apache Indian
hyannis kowalska I was hanging out with
the gentleman who live with them with
the Mongolian Eagle who's why six months
with you I was I'm out no let me just
ask you
yeah was it a white man tailless yeah
Wow it didn't come from the Indians
mouth no if it didn't come from a guy
named Geronimo no I don't care American
Indians didn't do that but the
Mongolians do it today Chen do me a
favor during up Eagle versus wolf
Mongolia on YouTube how about this oh
it's like you're ready to go chin there
it is
okay well that's awfully Photoshop leave
this stupid hat no that's an that's a
real Eagle now now that's an eagle
we haven't come out at night now that's
a that's a wolf Wow
now they won't let go that thing's back
they will not let go of that thing
and the wolf doesn't just [ __ ] them up
cries Oh trouble Santa nutbags team and
then they both jump on him how the rip
it is dick how crazy is that how crazy
is that and then you run up on your
horse and I suppose you would slay the
wolf if you need because he's tough I
would so I don't want to kill a wolf but
I had to see this to believe it
watch this he's that wolf is running and
they come out like death from the sky
the wolf's like what the silo death from
the sky since when do you girls attack
us right kind of evil demonic [ __ ] is
this exactly now that's crazy
now there are talons I guess or
something like like two now that's just
terrible
look at that if I had to pick a evil or
wolf I'm taking the wolf all gun oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] hate birds birds are crying you see
what he's doing is he's just holding on
here dude can you imagine if there were
real tear down yes doing this to human
like just yeah and that's what they say
that prehistoric birds the large ones
the ancestors of the harpy eagle and
stuff took human beings all the time
they take monkeys so with with monkeys
when you make an eagle sound monkeys
will like in in certain parts Riegel's
they look up they get [ __ ] tears so
if I'm in the jungle I go ah yes and in
fact there's another kind of monkey that
when he's being hunted by another type
of monkey rabbit and crows he'll make a
noise that mimics an eagle and then the
other monkey's run away
Jindo Eagles killing monkeys yeah
monkeys yeah bro the harpy eagle I think
welcome to male Cobra he means or
somewhere that they'll take they take
they take mine I've seen kill their
goats cuz they picked the goats open and
just drop them like [ __ ] yeah this
eagle attack monster we just check this
one out yes please
yeah I cannot believe that they're your
dogs not safe around giant Mongolian
Eagles good thing there's none in LA
there's a heartbeat that's a harpy eagle
you know third suck
and their talons are they can squeeze a
squeeze apparently they dig those nails
and your birds are [ __ ] stupid you
can't cuddle them they're kind of
worthless
you'll also turn the spies too you know
that shitload to make it seem like there
it goes
oh cool brought that monkey to his
babies brought that monkey to his babies
this is the worst video I've ever seen
maybe go back to there's one below it
they look pretty and then there are some
here's the guy who says stuff then there
there's video of eagles killing elephant
I don't see him kill that little cheetah
don't another one do baby cheetahs birds
are [ __ ] evil birds are birds or
reptiles but they're smart reptiles with
brains well they're dinosaurs they're
Dino the closest thing to dinosaurs we
have people think is an alligator wrong
dummies it's it's a bird don't be so
cocky though with your with your no
longer dummies take it easy
look at this right here there is all you
had thank you for that sure sorry that's
a slaw I was a sloth that's a three-toed
there it goes smash them he just took
him and passed the skull that's not fair
Oh coos ah and that that our ancestors
when we were hanging out we got what st.
Peters I know I know
so what they told you well they found
evidence of that scarring on prehistoric
skulls that suggests that it was a bird
of course it makes sense what this
happened to that monkey eloquently a
hunt more birds are kind of stupid
well as cute they do nothing there's an
amazing one of the best books I've ever
read called blood meridian by Cormac
McCarthy there's there's a guy they
called the judge he's a 7-foot albino
and he's the devil basically and he
leads this it's about it uh
autobiography now it's about a guy who
leads a group of scalp hunters in the
Earl in like the 1820s and in in the
United States and he's shooting birds
out of the sky he's just shooting fish
and there's these beautiful birds and
the captain comes up as his judge why do
you keep shooting these birds out of the
sky you know
11 him dying he goes they insult me with
their freedom that's funny
he's right they are free his [ __ ] there
they insult because they insult me with
their freedom isn't it weird that's our
national [ __ ] and I'm gonna bald
eagle it's a noble beasts they take [ __ ]
from no one
they swai they soar free is there
anything freer than an eagle what what
kills Eagles nothing but maybe even an
eagle calm man a man well actually what
kills a we should be the mask
chemicals chemicals in the environment
so their eggs don't hatch or their eggs
hatched prematurely but for the most
part yeah it's hard to kill an eagle we
never [ __ ] see him and they fly high
they fly high so good luck with your
shotgun can't take him out with a
scattergun if you kill a bald eagle
they've guys have lost our house over
that [ __ ] dude there was uh we had this
MC named Alfred great guy and he knew
every movie of all time but he was
talking about a documentary I haven't
watched it I've tried looking up last
night came out 2 and 13 you can get on
iTunes now or YouTube it's called unsung
hero have you heard of this no go to the
trailer chin this dude proposed his
girlfriend had like a baseball game live
on TV and she said no and you know why
she's a small dick so he goes on the
voyage and this documentary true story
of trying to find out if you can
actually get your dick bigger so there's
all around the world and tries to find
out like if he could do something to
make his date larger that's incredible
go the trailer is on here unsung hero
song hero I'm probably not the Mission
Control my god it's down there I'm here
second on the trailer let's see go down
right there
there you go jeez it's ok brendan is
very yeah very impatient it's not
impatient but with your age
this isn't it that's just a commercial
this is the sponsor this photo chengdou
unsung hero documentary so that's the
documentary this that be up Apollo yep
alright so
it no it's not unsung unhung Oh what the
[ __ ] is get specific unhung hero that's
funny that's different there this one
top one yes please click on that
you know those kiss cams they have it
sporting some embarrassing you see them
well look at what happened two days
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
really embarrassing Mohit you to by
Monday you must realize man with you my
name is Patrick moote and apparently I
have a small penis she told me that one
of the main reasons that she didn't
think that we were right for each other
was because my penis was a little too
small check out the jaw on Becky I don't
remember much I thought we were just
making out anybody said the size doesn't
matter I don't think that size matters
that yeah I fit small dick thing men of
the world deserve an answer to this
question and so I'm gonna find it with
this documentary who likes funny
this is so great or on this pad
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah Wow
the male body was not subject to a
critical gaze and now it is everybody
wants to have a big penis you open your
death you open your gear it's building
its soft spot because yes there's a
little flaccid penis if this is
important enough to you you're probably
gonna go after the penis enlargers I'm
just basically trying to find something
that'll work so get cherry tomato balls
[Music]
booster coffee look the guy [ __ ] him
up look they [ __ ] him up you'd be
filming in there oh my god
[Music]
watch this though dude do the dog who
does it that's terrible
what was that that he was putting in his
dick I'm sort of fluid okay so did you
watch it no I haven't seen them oh my
god I want to watch a memory what feels
like it's a mockumentary what do you
mean like it's a it's film to look like
a documentary no no I do sound he's a
real cam thing we got for you for the
Wilson thing oh yeah you're out of your
[ __ ] I see I just watch job it's it
funny it actually looks like a funny I'm
sure they took poetic license and it
looks like it's a funny you got to do
that when you do something but I do this
I do think that's what he's gonna it's
the same thing with like the way catfish
came about with Nev you know he was
originally catfished and did a
documentary on that was mission
happening this is the exact same thing I
don't think that that's my cue I don't
think it's fake I don't think that yeah
you know but wow what what a strange
situation and that interesting and and
he got left right there huh
what up don't do that don't put a woman
on first of all by the way also know ya
also know and also I admire the woman
though she didn't lie she was I can't do
it you know I've been better for her yes
and after like you know I can't do that
exactly you're such a small dick but
also just walked away
[ __ ] that does that UCLA mmm is a small
dick a deal-breaker like let's say women
found out Brad Pitt had V tiny stick is
that a deal-breaker do some I know of
some certain thing that's actually good
at everything else then yeah they're
real make up for it yeah they're be the
Swiss Army I think it also depends on
the girl like some girls can't get off
with just a dick yeah I know I know and
I will never never mention his name
because I feel for the guy but I know a
really famous actor like a really famous
guy who's like people who has a small
dick Morgan Freeman nope never say who
it is but I know
and here's important it makes sense to
me when I when I see him it like
a lot of minutes yeah I don't want to
just like be that guy give me a movie
does it rhyme with nothing I want to
protect his privacy but cap man no no is
it Michael Keaton yeah but no it's Vin
Diesel dude everyone knows that it's
been diesel no no it's actually not but
but um but sometimes actually I know if
to act there's nothing you can do if you
just have a smell hair is know you gotta
watch document okay yeah I looked up the
cliff notes on it there's actually
nothing can do the only thing they can
do this day and age I guess is cut where
that connects to your make it body and
it makes like two inches longer me not
even but that's about it so if you have
two inches you get four still small dick
I do believe there are women out there
that don't care there are some one
minute don't care
Oh for like it that one dude that died
Verne Troyer he had girlfriends well
then oh it's different how that's
different but yeah big dick small person
one there's no there are definitely
women that are you know like everything
there's women every Lego piece fern is a
fit somewhere yeah yeah but I don't know
just cuz Verne Troyer is a small Perseus
small dick Jen yeah I don't stop until I
got that operation Oh gross hey would
you rather have the one of the biggest
sticks in the world but a busted face or
the best face in the world in a small
dick without hesitation a busted face
and the biggest ignore oh I disagree
yep and I get Richie [ __ ] of what girls
don't care about your busted face if you
got money and a giant dong well your
well no one said you get riches [ __ ] no
you look like [ __ ] you look like Bill
Gates but you [ __ ] you know you don't
have his money but you got a fat dick
Daniel AIDS and you just work you like
or I'm a great looking guy with a little
dick I couldn't deal with pulling my
pants down and having the girl be
excited then go so it'd be tough I'll
take the huge dick and I'll just be the
happy surprise I'll be the I'll be you
know ugly on top and some guys are some
guys that surprised you man
some guys like Wow good for you man
yeah yeah some guys have got are working
with a crazy piece a crazy piece and
I'll say about him right now I know who
Dwarfs both of us
Nova said this all the time I've seen it
nope you think I say Julia no you say
Rogan
no who Stevie blue eyes oh no Jay Schwab
got this all beat J shop you've never
seen his J shop I've seen I see tamo
first of all I saw his flaccid [ __ ]
Toyota I saw it flaccid and I we were at
artsplace and empower really oh you're
changing the laws changing I saw his
dick and I went first of all let's stop
everything why are you not walking
around in spandex with no underwear
number one number two why is this the
first time I'm hearing or seeing this
I've told you everyone June you haven't
given me the proper to Tamil like it's a
piece and I have he's got just hanging
low he looks like he looks like such an
offensive weapon it's a panther tail
it's AB it's a goddamn I went I went and
it's black it's super so dark I went oh
it's this huge black dick bro hey I
think it he's got I think it's a
birthmark his dick is dicks all black
[ __ ] as black it's a black man's dick
and he has a black dick yeah it's just a
big one no I understand - cool and when
we're in high school you'd shower at the
local gym there and the dudes in the hot
tub would just stare exist it's distract
I couldn't take it he's like the [ __ ]
you staring at like a giant like dick
it's very odd to see around it is and
he's got a very very white skull think
you need one were gay but it's very
distracting he's got he's got ivory
white skin with a giant black dick like
he could open up a [ __ ] just a booth
on Venice Beach and have decent money
yes he could don't check out the white
guy with a black dick and and another
thing about J shop he'll surprise you
and I've said this before he's got an
excellent body when he takes you he's
very muscular so you go well you get the
and then you got that and then you got
the David Blaine face what's going on
here but not quite as good-looking as
david says something's going on yeah
either way congrats Jay Congrats on it
was he in sialic oh yeah your brother
always makes me feel good when he's
around I miss him
and I try to have nosy and I call you
guys brothers hey brother hey brothers I
have a thing that talked about it do you
know he's missing forget what show I
think when I'm in New Mexico cuz he's
gonna do Japan he's so into racing he's
going to Japan to watch the races he's
going to wait what we're races he likes
those formula like the the Lewis
Hamilton I can't get into it how you owe
me on my cars I know you don't like
Formula One I think you know I think
that's so why so so what's I don't know
I'm just done in - I like regular cars
what's funny about you as you drive your
car slowly and let's just lay that night
in the 405 yeah no you know Jay just got
an all red cherry red gt3 for him Oct 3
GT 3 damn
it's [ __ ] the thing is sick he loves
I don't think he's posted about it he's
always weird like a lot yours Instagram
I speak sure you post like me and him
and Dublin or some [ __ ] like two years
ago if you're not in entertainment
there's no reason I agree I wouldn't if
I didn't have to sell things I would not
be on social I think it's I think it's a
nightmare
you think silly yeah it's not good and
the other thing is Jay his was private
forever because Sony Sochi when we
talked about his dick people I kid him
up like big dick bandit and he like he
said people would walk by his office my
good so big dick you like dude it come
on yeah he doesn't like it like his
bosses like do come on you know what Jay
we would edit this out but we're not
going to I can't do it I hope you get
harassed yeah Jake's killing that
Japanese October is it seventh the
seventh so maybe not the one the
Japanese Grand Prix maybe that is the
one he's going to I don't know he's
headed
Japan soon those guys make Bank formula
1 racers and it's like Leo you know
there's 12 slots available yeah and
there they all start when they're very
young you know Lewis Hamilton is dating
Nicki Minaj now I think it's funny cuz I
was in The Breakfast Club with
charlemagne and DJ MV Lewis Hamilton I'm
sorry Lou Samson's number-one racecar
driver in the world
mix man what mom's wipe dad's black I
think handsome dude yeah Tommy Hilfiger
model and then also the best race car
driver in the world cheese but his
father would put so much pressure on him
to win because such an expensive sport
he's now the best in the world
he's been connected to Kardashians he's
a straight dimepiece and uh he's he's
worth like 320 million dollars
and it was funny listen The Breakfast
Club cuz like Nicki Minaj got a new man
and Charlemagne's like bring up his net
worth is this guy just milking offer
like Jesus Christ like he's a big
[ __ ] deal Richard in America he's not
that huge well if you know race guy is
but in internationally he's a [ __ ] so
she's super I the first black or mixed
owes Nicki Minaj Formula One race where
isn't he that I can think of I always
thought of him as white European guy I
mean he she's uh and she weathered the
storm wondered what's normal Oh with
yeah she's fine they took her ticket
sales went up after all that all that
stuff that's how it works
have you mean J we're talking about this
have you seen no Katt Williams has just
been relentlessly hating on the Kevin
Hart no just [ __ ] on Kevin now and
Kevin Hart came out was like dude why
Kevin Hart came out said hold on you've
had your shot you were supposed to be
the guy but you chose drugs yeah well I
chose to work and then now you an
African Americans at the top and you
want to bring me down he goes dude it's
not it's not like I'm taking gigs away
from you so me and J were talking about
this cuz in in rap it's gonna sell more
CD's and rap they seem to sell more
albums for Kanye West's it sells more
shoes wins controversial in comedy means
you ever talk about this if if Katt
Williams now was going to staple centers
or whatever I'm probably not going to
show economy I don't like when you hate
other guys like oh I'm out man and you
know what um
he's he's hanging on Tiffany Haddish
when I saw Katt Williams I know Tiffany
for many years Tiffany is one of the
nicest people on the planet
well that's hey Tiffany has always been
I've known Tiffany I don't know I've
known Tiffany maybe ten years one that
Tiffany has always been super nice to
everybody
Tiffany's never been anything but a good
person
well yeah everyone knows that she's a
great person but what Kevin Hart says
about Tiffany hash that's what he went
after
Katt Williams he's like hold on you're
coming after her because she has a huge
lead and this movie you're saying she's
not funny cuz you guys talked about you
want equal this and how we never get our
rights and then when when they do gets
our tours you're [ __ ] on them yeah
you say it doesn't make sense and that's
what
Tiffany's been nothing but nice oh dude
Tiffany's a great person and she
deserves that and Tiffany didn't have an
easy childhood you know but anyway I
know she's been doing stand-up since she
was 17 so she does Donner eras comedy
shop Network thing up the last I did
that's it she's a kid how crazy is that
yes but but then but then Katt Williams
like yo he claims Kevin Hart brought up
the Tiffany House beef to sell night
school tickets you just in this I'm a
huge Katt Williams fan too you're just
wrong dude cuz Kevin Hart is his last
five movies have all been number one and
the only
- without weren't were number two in the
world so he's not you know I saw Katt
Williams at the Comedy Store probably
five years ago and he blew me away
he's one of I want you been I watched
him as a comic in it I was already
established I've been doing stand-up for
a long time really some people say I do
pretty well and I and I watched him and
I went I was so inspiring I went that
[ __ ] is so good and I didn't
know he was and he was talking in the
hobby that was the height of his I
walked up to him I go dude I
that was amazing and he just turned to
me and he goes okay thanks man
but yeah welcome to the cab and I mean I
knew but I didn't know I ever seen him
but but I'm him the bomber is when
you're that good the bummer is when
you're that good and then you go bad on
Kevin Hart but the nicest most generous
human be like Kevin says he's there I
don't get him in nobody has any but he
had a good point he's like dude Mike
Epps hates on them and count wouldn't
say thumbs like dude you guys had you
I'm just hating on yeah he's like you
guys had your opportunity and he goes
but again while you guys chose drugs and
alcohol I chose to work and now I'm here
and you guys want to [ __ ] on me but I
was I was just thinking like beef and
rap or beef when it comes to act or
something like that it's not like I'm
not gonna go see a movie if the Rockets
are Mark Wahlberg oh my god whatever
that's throne deal but with comedy I'm
like God when you're when you're doing
this crap thing and trying to bring down
that you're stepping all over each other
I can't support that no I'm out also
it's also not fun let me ask you this as
a man as a woman as a human being
like if you have beef with somebody are
you gonna go to social media and [ __ ]
tear them down so anyway they can't but
it makes cat relevee
right and Kevin Hartz the biggest name
and you have a connection to it's a bad
news especially I mean black or white
comics one the top ten of all time so
when he says something it carries weight
so that's why that's a shitty way to go
about your life it's not the
negativities not the way to go so the
negativity gets brought up if Katt
Williams would have said Kevin Hart's
the best of all time he's so great I
hope he keeps doing good
there's no right on no right up on that
there's no news article there's nothing
which is the bummer in our society it's
a [ __ ] bummer man that depresses me
it really does because it gives people
who have negative things to say more
power than people have positive things
to say i Kevin Hart just keeps on keep
on oh very cool my [ __ ] mind movies
number one I don't yeah and and I just
sold out 60,000 yes Theatre odd because
they used to talk about that because it
would always say no matter what happens
war famine people saying bad [ __ ] about
me I just keep painting well what'd you
say yeah cool I'm painting you just keep
moving forward that's all you can do
keep doing what you're doing so well but
out do you see Steve Harvey Steve Harvey
a guy named Pusha T who's a huge in the
rap game was associated with Kanye West
saw that stuff but he went balanced
Steve Harvey and you know Steve Harvey
host all those shows he's a used to be a
big-time comic steve harvey and a real
kind I came real legit [ __ ] Connery
most people don't know that but Steve
Harvey in between his shows he just
talks to the crowd he goes off on Pusha
T he's like I don't give a [ __ ] what
Pusha T says my name does he don't pay
my bills I never heard the guy but do
you have this clip chin he's whereas
about him he's like I watch this and it
does his thing let me see there's no one
this is that family feud mind you this
is the crowded family feud yeah it's
right there turn up its rolling with
Steve Harvey
pushes back at push it T do you know how
that don't move the needle in my life
you know I've said negative about me in
rap songs they said positive most of us
cool some other day do you think I care
what a rapper thinks of me a rapper
don't I don't give a [ __ ] what a singer
thinks I don't really give what a
politician think of me
not watching TV one day you know Joe I
heard Joe Losey one of my favorite
preachers on TV I love this dude Joel
Osteen said people's opinion of you is
none of your business nor should you
make it yours
all right guys what somebody think of
you what differs doing me they don't
even know you
I could care less man they rapping about
you Dwight girl song counsel in the
background you in a rap song push your
teeth he says something about you who
push your teeth where's your teeth at
will help me with none of my bills ain't
sending none of my kids through school
Pusha T don't answer my prayers push
your T don't give me health don't that
dad rapping you got weird at the end
there you know weird at the end it's
great that the crowd was like this it's
great though so funny no I was I was
with him till he started rapping Luke
Rousey is why he was just doing her
office he didn't rhyme at least and you
riding my seven bars out of nowhere you
ride like my dad yeah yeah it's awkward
though huh yeah it's funny though yeah
it's very true well that's my education
you saw the fill out so I'm gonna bet
I'll see like one of you there's none of
your business what people think about
you is none of your business that's very
good yeah what are you gonna do it's a
very good point
I agree what how what did you do when we
were gone this weekend
I tried to go see my friends show but it
got sold out so I can hook you up with
tickets no she's got family for her comp
tickets that's [ __ ] up so he got sold
out that's good though yeah shows that
USC usually go pretty quickly unless
it's in the big theater no but than that
I just worked sort of new job yep work
seven days a week seven days yep I work
every single day Jesus Christ the grind
is real is real goddamn you had some
crude events Jen Canaan yeah we got some
for you and the first ones are cats she
can pick whatever orders oh yeah oh my
god this is great speaking of dicks so
Batman's penis made it into a comic book
and now it's a collector's item no and a
lot of people are underwhelmed talked
about this on TMZ yeah let me see
they're starting a new comic book line
within DC that's separate from their
other storylines where it's a darker
comic so they'll have much more things
like nudity sex violence and stuff like
that you see x-ray yeah and so their
first comment book coming out is gonna
be a Batman series and it's gonna be
Nightwing as before you became Nightwing
he took a minute and became Batman so it
was Robin good Robin took over Batman's
post after Bruce Wayne died and so this
is where the comic starts and they have
like an outline of his penis so terrible
people are mad that's that's basically
area I grew up watching the animated
series and there was a scene where
Nightwing which is the same character
playing Batman in this series [ __ ]
Harlequin and I just expected more in my
head yes what is that is that is that
that's hard
no that's soft he's just walking now I
mean see I would like to see more girth
and I would like to see a lower hang and
and I have to say this as well little
does look like there I'd like to see
some heavy heavy impossible balls
because if you look out Vasco his The
Dark Knight is a very strong macho
man I need more testosterone so he
should have a set of bull balls and I
believe his [ __ ] should be simply too
big and the kind of things of
superheroes should be a fat day I need I
need I can't have an average dick on
Batman lorries on so much sauce is ball
shrunk up now Brandon if you're gonna
say Batman does steroids I'm gonna
probably he's on physically attack he's
doing no no hold on let me rephrase that
listen I don't mean like he's on some
androids I mean Batman thumb all hold
that's to give you another chance
Oh take all of it back alright and cuz
I'm gonna come at you okay I know
Brandon Batman's all natural true or
false
[Music]
sorry about that sorry about that
that's however Batman is just a rich
dude on TRT with cool gadgets he is
Superman Superman is a real dude who
probably doesn't have TRT love to have
forms well technically Superman's an
alien but correct yeah I just in comic
books look at the way they draw women
fat tits big ass I just expected more
from Batman stick that to then I see
that CAD you're clearly a size Queen and
I appreciate that right yeah I mean it's
Batman bro it's Batman
it is Batman alright what are you happy
very happy with Lindsay Lohan tried to
kidnap two kids from their parents well
apparently it's a grin limes dick do you
have the video yeah it's on here yes she
is soft in the face yeah she gets sucked
through the face by the mom I couldn't
watch place no uncomfortable guys you're
going the wrong way Michael is here
what's happening they're trafficking
children shut up and I heard sure I
won't leave until I take you why is she
talking like yeah what is she acquired a
new accent after dating this Middle
Eastern guy don't [ __ ] with me hey kids
these are Syrian refugees I believe this
is the Arab this is not Arab you're
ruining our culture by doing this
she's so crazy you're taking these
children they want to go this is her
this is I'm host:you I'm with you I'm
with you boys don't worry the whole
world is seeing this right now hello
hello
she sang Shalom I think right speaking
Hebrew a Syrian woman is so pleased she
tried to take the kids walk forever I'd
say with your doing I stay with you Tory
is your son well that mom right there
I'm [ __ ] son
it's poor people one [ __ ] son they've
already been enough Sporto and that in
the things that not these mom look at
this it's a family you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] get us the mom that's the mama
Brit bear it's not illegal about herself
look yes the kids where's her accent at
though though exactly she's not
Lindsey's not dude see I don't think
she's an I don't think she's ever done
drugs
okay anyways bubbly song about how many
drugs you have to do before you pick up
an Arabic accent she's Shalom that come
with me come with me come here she had
an English accent for a little while
yeah [ __ ] yeah so we'll booze yeah she
thought the mom was trying to traffic
the BA the two kids yeah that's why she
i've spent a little time lindsay so and
the mom sucked the [ __ ] out of her yeah
you're [ __ ] right man yeah i've had
my experience she's hilarious
yeah what else we got there's definitely
sex trafficking going on it's a problem
but i think she's that was a family with
their children that was a refugee family
with their children so cardi be turned
herself in to the police today over a
strip club fight so a while back there
uh we're room well not rumors it was
confirmed but offset cheated on cardi B
with a bartender from a club that he was
performing out with the rest of them
egos and this is her longtime man not
long time maybe like a year they're
married but according to new sources
that a fight broke out a lot of people
said that cardi actually put out a hit
on two girls I don't know why to when
only one of them slept with offset but
she put a hit out apparently on two
girls that worked at the bar not to kill
him just to beat him up yeah just to
beat him up back viewers
that she sent men to go beat us women
right however there are other sources
who were there at the club that said
that a drink was thrown at her while she
was at that club and she started a fight
with the people that she was with the
probably makes more sense yeah which i
think is more accurately questions
because if you watch love and hip-hop
and how she was on there that's more
actually feisty for sure I don't think
she's done what I think she can get away
or and a hitman to beat up these guys
that [ __ ] her man yeah so she turned
herself in today not arrested but she
has to show up in court should be
alright though she also walked out like
nothing was wrong saying hi to her fans
yeah she's great I know a guy who I'll
tell you who it is ever there's a guy
who did a documentary on a hitman and he
brought it I think to MTV and MTV saw it
and the guy was a real hit man like he's
like he'd kill somebody for $10,000 and
it was a really interesting but empty
because you have to get this out of our
building yeah get out of our thing I
don't want to see this so Kanye West
performed on SNL this past weekend
because ariana grande dropped out last
minute and he performed several songs
one of them with little pomp where he
dressed up as a Perrier bottle and
little pump was dressed as a Fiji wattle
it is such a kick out of the funny with
this if your little pump though you're
all Dini all right I get aware of Pete
the [ __ ] Fiji baubles Ronnie to me
life debut on Saturday Night Live
members chuckle Rob uh you ever see his
old fights night and everybody come out
with like they'd have advertisements and
you come out with water he had a t-shirt
just yeah water that didn't Kanye then
kind of go bad on the 13th amendment
13th amendment is the amendment yeah
outlawed sleep yeah you wanna you went
on a huge Pro Trump rant that they cut
off he wore make America great
he always was that though he's a trump
supporter for he's making it you know
you know I'm a Kanye fan for his fashion
and his stuff but enough for his
politics yeah but say you know he make
it tough to be a fan sometimes yeah but
what was the 13th amendment thing what
was that about well he released a tweet
after the SNL performance once all of
the videos of the speech after SNL cut
the footage yeah came out because I
Oliva was on Chris Rock's Instagram page
he put it on his story little snippets
of Chania going on a Trump rant after
that performance we have the bring up do
we have on is right there a buddy of
mine is a comic who's black was talking
about Kanye I had a conversation with
him about this and he said this to me he
thought I was really funny he goes if I
want if I want music I listen to Kanye
West if I want politics if I want a good
interesting political point of view I
don't go to a rapper or a musician or an
artist I go usually to somebody where
that's their field it's like anything
else said everyone ever yeah so you know
sometimes it's like I'll have to take it
that seriously make you bigger chin
Chris Rock's laughing
then you got a situation where we need
to have a dialogue and not a diatribe
and if you want something to change is
evident la New York writers rappers
musicians so it's easy to make it seem
like it's Sol Sol Sol one side well that
was terrible yeah he went on a rant and
then he tweeted the next day saying that
he wants to make America great again
to have factories stop being outsourced
to other countries and create more
American jobs to give jobs to prisoners
and to abolish the Thirteenth Amendment
which outlawed slavery I don't know what
he meant by that I don't either but but
the thing about the thing I will say is
I do think this country needs to be
talking to each other a little more we
are broken up into serious teams and its
really polarized but you know what you
know it's funny as he goes on this ran
about Thirteenth Amendment but before
that he was singing a song called I
[ __ ] love like he was talking about
porn again he's dressed as a waterbomb
he's it complicated it's like you know
what by the way well said by the way
hold on sir you were just dressed like a
water bottle sir I'm sorry I want you
I'm porn I'm sorry is any we can take
off the the water bottle outfit before
you rant on amendment 13 and now America
should be great that is a that is a
contradiction right that you know if
you're walking in if you look like a few
if you if I walk in and I'm dressed like
a blow-up sex doll and anime sex doll
you know I got everybody get down I
talked you about your life here alright
here's the thing Kanye appreciate the
music it's hard to listen to you about
making America great because I'm sorry
you're on stage with a man named is it a
little pump little pump and you're
dressed as two water bottles water and
the song's called I love it and you talk
about how you like to [ __ ] girls
so we're little confused you give me a
minute to minute that's all in yeah cuz
that some of this confused was Caitlyn
Jenner but we'll give us a sec that's
right that's right give us a second to
soak this all in that's exactly right
I mean it's hard for me to talk to you
about it's like if I go into a
psychiatrist's office and I want to talk
about my life and he's dressed he's got
giant [ __ ] outfit on I'm gonna be like
can you take the penis outfit off first
that's tough man yeah what else yet he
also wants to change his name from Kanye
to yay yay yep going by yay now radical
she did really about black and white
band-aids can't like that one
so one another once there was the
band-aid there and I put it on him he
didn't like the color of the mandate and
so we went upstairs in the kids room and
I go oh look North has Jesus band-aids
put on a Jesus band-aid so he was like I
exclaimed around the world making
clothes for you to make sure that you
find the best outfit and you let me go
out wearing a Jesus band-aid he said I
should have got a skin colour band-aid
and I'm like you know I'm running around
to find three and different color
band-aids well your assistance but yeah
I keep this dress why can't you get it
you would get Saint one and I'm like oh
my god are you fighting with Saint isn't
sorry it's a good thing I was like this
is not gonna be this way and I'm not
gonna have a full-fledged fight cuz I
won't get you a band-aid I'm sorry this
is what couples fight about
that's right about little shop [ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean just that's that you
can get into relationship ending
arguments over an over crazy little [ __ ]
like that I'm with Kanye though don't
give me a goddamn white band-aid I'm
gonna try give me one I meant I'm not
that white better get a brown band
needed a brown band
yeah I don't want it all sticking out
you wanted to blame me over colored
band-aid bro yeah give me a tan band-aid
I have to go with the the see-through I
guess these are just a bread one yeah
red band red pink red pink off green
yellow
you got any well I need pink with yellow
hues to do it please I'm with Kennedy
though what else we got that's it right
there
that's it for cat's new cat cat news for
cat news that's it you like the sound
effect yeah DDT yeah um little sketch in
Elon Musk
you know he's tweeted out that there's
company Michael private Tesla yeah which
was sort of a which was basically a lie
yeah so he was fined and punished by the
SEC and since then he lost 20 million
dollars and he had to resign as chairman
of Tesla
damn still that hair transplant here's
still looking fresh though well that
have you seen him before yeah intertext
my [ __ ] yeah that's me 21 dodge by some
hair and a by some hair buddy um so he's
out huh we're just jammin yeah so he
still is his he's still brilliant making
all the [ __ ] yeah you don't want him
running it I didn't follow when what the
Riddler running your business I got fine
he's a great self promoter he's like
he's but but I didn't follow what he did
he said the company might go privates
for the stock something happens to the
stock I got you the investors you just
can't do that he just runs like he's run
it without running it like a proper
business and it scares investors and
writers so their skin a regular
businessman in there well I'm
considering taking Tesla private at Fort
120 bucks funding secured that wasn't
pretty deliberate I was in truth it was
like what yeah the board members like
what the [ __ ] yeah and then you can't be
like my bat right so just shows you a
little unhinged
they say they freaked out to these
didn't see smoked weed on row again so
there's that and yeah the whole world
goes crazy like dude we can't trust this
guy so basically they're doing dude just
step down so everyone you know buddy
there's a large part of Elon Musk that
wants to be celebrity and famous and
he's liked another person somebody
saying he's the Thomas Edison of our
time Thomas Edison had something like
eleven hundred patents but Thomas Edison
was the guy who owned a company where he
hired a lot of inventors and people were
working and then he would take a
ownership of that of that patent ativ
yeah well no but there's nothing wrong
with that he was pushed against all your
ideas and and Elon Musk is considered a
guy who's a great self promoter he's a
guy who takes risks but sometimes
sometimes he's he's he's a very good
marketer it doesn't mean he's a genius
at everything and obviously I think what
he does he's a genius
I think Couto just probably hating
hating this between Thomas Edison him
and I think it's a very apt one yeah I
don't know if anyone's know I do think
there's a huge part of him that has a
huge ego and he wants I think is
he's very brilliant yeah he's a and he's
and he takes risk and I Drive his car
and I think it was a you know but he did
he did make that car possible with huge
government help huge government
subsidies right so that car that I Drive
right now would usually I wouldn't it
would cost me 120 grand as opposed to 70
grand and that's because of health from
the US government still gotta give him
credit he got the write-off
so you know mm-hmm a little bit of shade
at Elon so you know it's stocks dropped
when he did that one tweet and then when
he resigned finally they're back up you
know when I you know when I went a
little south on him the Thai kids yeah
that's when I went south on him a little
bit I found that very disappointing that
he would do that I took a guy right yeah
I thought it was very petty yeah and it
said a lot about who he is I went oh
you're you I'm not gonna matter I'm not
gonna bring down just for that i don't
yeah i'm pretty forgiving but that was
the one thing i was like that's a nasty
thing to some call somebody you know it
was just it was gross and it was about
him and those kids were still in that in
that it was yeah but you do drive his
car so you only can do [ __ ] you don't
need this to keep drivers gonna keep
paying that lease every man I'll do you
one better
my my tree up I'm at least get a new one
yeah so bad but I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna be pissed when I do it there you
go I mean I don't approve in that
comment but I'll take that I'll take the
car I'll support you because there's so
much to that right I don't [ __ ] that
[ __ ] but I'm and get that car but
that Tesla's nice enough she got to make
a good product this you can bring
marijuana to the airport now no before
it was you couldn't bring it to a
government or a federal property which
is it the airlines are the airport yeah
so now you can bring it really up to 8.5
Millett final Eagle where do you land
that's on yeah my boy Matt the
photographer in Chicago he you know he
goes with Gucci man they're all over the
place and he you know he has to always
look where they're gonna land because
you know he likes smoking weeds I always
ask to check the rules and the
regulations wherever he lands you're
[ __ ] but you're not really [ __ ] of
it's just personal there's a constant we
have a ransom if you say we'll toss it
now those tossing most of them well cuz
they're not tops they're not esa it's
not calm
they're not a government body you know
they're just like yeah you can't have
this dude
my buddy four cops near then your [ __ ]
my buddy got to the airport and had no
idea losses oh no I've been there and
and TSA oh my god and the TSA guys do
you think you think you're the only one
come on over and they did like some
check there's other stuff you can do
yeah there's a it's a hassle it takes
some time but you can do it but he got
on the plane I guess they know you can't
not if international can't do that
no well you can't get a no country about
okay guys yeah the International part
and in China I had to do a finger scan
and a retinal scan and my passport
finger retinal Passport thanks guys make
sure you keep track of me I'm coming be
an actor you know all right so this was
at an event in New York the global
citizen festival I guess a big barricade
fell down and of course it's a huge
crowd lots of people and see here some
of the artists that play there first of
all you see that you see all those
people yeah
I'm never going to that yep so that's
why they freaked out they heard the
sound they thought was gunshots so that
people start fleeing and they had to
have that guy from Coldplay do anything
there was no serious injuries that I
heard of but you can see the running
right here this is some of it
the people run they're actually they're
just kind of moving out of the way this
is the news of almost happened somebody
tripped those current events with here's
a concert where people were scared and
then kind of walked mosey down although
I do understand cuz I'm not going to
that
global citizen which is ain't cool too
many people videotape it and I'll watch
it on the news I'm not I don't like
parades I don't like large crowds no
thank you too busy no unless I have a
lot of bulletproof armor and big guns
then it's not funny either and it's not
hard to listen to me it's hard to listen
then heavy heavy it's heavy stuff on you
what else did you want to talk about the
Earl Thomas thing at all to get into
what do you have any fun ones chin yummy
funny what nothing what is that you go
to barstool or anything
yeah Barstow sir but there's nothing's
good okay just world Thomas is a guy who
was like I covered him with my other
show he was a safety for the Seattle
Seahawks he was like a long time staple
of the Legion of boom and want a
long-term contract and then they didn't
give it to him and he felt pressure to
play and then he was like I [ __ ] I'll
play and then broke his leg yesterday
Stan I don't get paid really did you
watch Bellator fights too didn't he Rory
MacDonald fight surprised you or how bad
he got his ass whooped surprise yeah you
tell you just frozen that was Obama yeah
I just didn't feel like fighting big
airs a terrible matchup for him why is
that
he just way bigger they're both so good
it's just I didn't know gay guys - how
much bigger oh [ __ ] yeah yeah big dude
yeah it's just a bad match not ufc's
this weekend brother I'm Connors to be
what do you think
um we I had a khabees team captain here
this morning you did yeah I my feeling
is that khabib has been an athlete his
whole life right and he's and he's a guy
who just what I like about khabib is he
goes out he beats you and when he's and
he does want to hurt anybody when he was
fighting he was saying I think was it
Michael transfer my job just stop stop
just buddy it's my you know yeah by the
Ignite unites belongs to me just stop
buddy I don't wanna hurt you play
there's a grace it belongs to me you
know it's mine no it's mine oh so you
didn't want to tell you good guy good
guy I thought to myself what a [ __ ]
he's just an athlete I know and he goes
out there to compete and he's been doing
it since he was three and I feel like
with Connor he wants to change his face
and career now that's either a good
thing or a liability
my feeling is a guy who's been competing
that long he's not gonna let himself get
too carried away but when he gets an
opening with with Connor he's going to
tie him up and he's going to beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of him
the fight rests on this can kind of stop
to take down and knock him out it's a
five-round fight then they then the next
question is can khabib take him down in
five rounds and punish him and my guess
is that's what's gonna happen
I don't know how you keep could be able
off you I don't know how you stand up
once he takes you down even though you
brought Jordan burrows in your camp
it's khabib nurmagomedov right yeah so
you need a you need a Greco guy a Samba
guy whatever it is
so for me my call is look for khabib to
pound his face and then look for khabib
to maybe
rip his ankle off because khabib is a
leg lock no no he won't
no that's not his thing that's not his
thing but he's good at those that's what
he's a Samba grab it uh-uh no you think
he just he doesn't do though you think
he wears I'm like a backpack loops that
leg and just IV I think I think it's a
dog fight I think it's back and forth I
think Abby does get him down but people
are gonna be surprised at Connors
movement and bill to get back up I think
he's way underrated on the ground I
think Conor lands shots I think it's a
straight-up dogfight I think the classic
rose judges
decision people are pissed at the
decision really needs a lot better
fighting everyone thing first of all I
don't think Connors gonna starch them I
don't think a Bebe's gonna just
absolutely mall them I think we got a
[ __ ] dogfight so Sonny is back and
forth think could be comes out on top
like the first two rounds maybe he's
taking him down he's controlling it but
Connor has his moments then the third
and fourth khabees gonna start to get
tired Connors gonna be tired too but is
gonna be more light on his feet he's
gonna land bigger shots wobble could be
khabib gifts maybe it starts to get just
one takedown around but Connors laying
the bigger shots so the judge is way
that a little more that goes in that
fifth round DC and Rogan black guy got a
2 2 what a fight and then I see that 5th
round just being fireworks Wow because
it's a dog I think I don't know anyone
else calling as a dog but I think most
people go dude unless Connor lands early
this thing's over yeah I don't see it
that way if cubby people are gonna be
surprised would agree that Connor is a
much higher level striker than could be
Oh Mike yes yes it could be could be
strike in his very element yes like even
Josh Thompson was saying is their head
strength coach Javier Mendes is like
yeah it's not like but I'm not gonna
tell him to do anything different he's
undefeated we've never lost a round
exactly I'm gonna tell me grow up then
strike with Connor no and I think khabib
is gay and I can see Connor is obviously
worried about the wrestling so what
Connor is doing in the press conference
is you grab people's legs you're a [ __ ]
you don't that's I'm not even fighting
so he's trying to get him to go to go to
him into standing with him well he knows
he's not but you know I think I think
khabib he has to get him against the
wall he has to he I don't think it'll
take him down from the open Connors foot
works too good but he asked him against
the wall coming into that striking
distance into the wall it's not that sim
Barboza I mean lit the [ __ ] it's a much
bigger weight cut for khabib because
khabib walks around when he's in the
offseason that like as heavy as 190 195
he came in a he said when he came into
the press conferences 174 so he's a much
bigger than a framed guy than Connors a
little taller but what's in there almost
the same height but Connor has a 4-inch
reach event that's significant in that
in that when when they're in striking
distance but once against the case that
wake up would have to weigh on khabib I
would imagine in the fourth and fifth
round although has it I'm so but he but
he hasn't but this is my thing with
khabib is
he's never lost around he's undefeated
what happens if he does lose around what
happened if things don't go his way what
happens when he's in the biggest fight
of his life what is what has he reacted
I think he's such a competitor and been
there so often that haven't been there
so often how he's never ever been in a
big fight what's never been he's never
been in that sense you're saying no he's
never had the pressure the magnitude of
find a car McGregor the magnitude of
being the biggest UFC event of all
taking magnitude of conor mcgregor's
fans in the arena all rooting against
you the magnitude of everything that
this fight represents he's ever been
there
yeah so I'm sure his cardio is gonna
take some hit to that yeah cuz your
Adrenaline's me through the roof yes
Conor's been there Conor what Connor
wants to do is go I've seen what Connor
does he goes I'm a stack all the chips
on our fight I've been here before man I
know how I react how are you gonna react
yeah
and he's hoping that it gets khabib a
little more passed apparently Eddie
Alvarez who has had his share of
competition and as a warrior experienced
amazing any of us said something to the
effect of I new to circle right and I
circled left like I knew or whatever the
way it was in other words circle away
from that left hand I knew that that's
what you're supposed to do obviously and
somehow I circle toward his left hand
I just got taken out of my game and even
Dustin Poirier I said you know I
he did get into my head probably he got
into my head at one point you know so
it's really hard to get the dog fight
man I think we have to these two elite
fighters and they're representing you
know - it's more than just a fight what
about ring Russell Conor
it's me I may be but when you talking
about Ireland versus Russia man and
dagestan you're talking about it's
bigger than those two you're gonna get a
dogfight
I'll get you I guarantee mr. Vladimir
Putin's gonna be watching this fight I'm
sure all of Russia there's a shitload of
pressure on both these guys but I'd say
there's more pressure on khabib because
I don't have the community buddy cuz
khabib is represent both of them yeah
well collars the face of the UFC he is
but like he hasn't fought for so long he
I don't know he's such a personality if
he loses he loses well you know but I'm
surprised to hear you say that uh that
you think Conor will be able to
neutralize his wrestling and that's not
neutralized
he's gonna get taken as he attained down
a bunch but I don't you know Kobe's not
a finisher he's not a guy who
who's gonna break cuz wears on you he'd
where's Anya I think Connors gonna have
his chances to get get up and make the
fight but nobody nobody's ever been able
to get up right no how do you win
wrestlers I went a big guy yeah but but
what what would you tell him do you take
the Iaquinta rulebook does that work for
Conor stand up stand up stand up no I
just think you know I just think he
needs to do his thing and and just and
just know and embrace the takedown and
you know Connors get [ __ ] Connors
good man he swept Nate dear the ex guard
sweep he's [ __ ] talented on the
Gracias he trains with Dylan Danis like
he changed some of the top guys in the
world like he's not gonna be a newbie
did what did khabib x' captain said he
or anything that would give you insight
I was surprised he told me some stuff
off here but he told me on there that he
thinks Habib's gonna win this fight
retire he's done mm-hmm since all I
wants to do is win this he still lives
with his parents and his wife and two
kids Wow
he just wants to win this fight and be
done with it Wow to beat the UFC poster
boy and get the [ __ ] out which I was
surprised and also awesome to hear I
think it's great so he rides off in the
sunset 2700 dogs I want to see a
national hero yeah my blood into
politics so my buddy blue Jeremy Blum
yeah so he has been he got recession to
Iser by Jean which is like Dagestan is
the same area and and his son has been
arrested in Long Beach in fact his coach
was tito ortiz tito comes Adam t10
coaches and there's a wrestling club in
a nice special on every corner and blue
said basically you go there and in the
basement of pretty much every building
just a shitty basement or a an old
basketball court there's anywhere from I
don't know 15 to 30 40 kids all from the
ages of like seven to like 14 their
coach is a world champion they all one
who to be they all want to be they all
wrestle like [ __ ] and at one
point you said there is this wrestling
club and some of the boys were talking
they were they were kind of being a
little bit rude and so they were all
told to line up and they all lined the
[ __ ] up and their coach walked by each
and every one of them these kids range
from Oh
I don't know 9 to 14 or 15 and they got
a good tight paint brushing you know
what a paintbrush in this it's when you
take your hand you slap one side then
you take your back hand looks just like
the other side give yourself a good
strong gut and everyone else kids took a
[ __ ] whack to the face and didn't say
boom and just went sat back down shut
the [ __ ] up and then practiced her to
get it they don't [ __ ] around
yeah it's rough out there but dagestan
especially I think MMA has now been by
the president declared the national
sport well it's like I could say paying
with our national animal I mean he says
he owns MMA league so he doesn't know of
course yeah an art either way great
fight do you think it breaks paper you
record to it - Dana sites trying on 2.5
I think it's full of [ __ ] I don't I
don't think it breaks - millions I never
better feel for this I know I'm not
missing that for the world
me neither but but but um I think it
does well I think it does somewhere you
know I I don't think I don't know if it
beats countering ideas - it does it be
Canelo the Canelo triple G fight what
does that do one better we know I think
yeah would that work does it beat that
was that was that huge that it should be
that yeah cuz that would be surprising
because it'll be I better beat that what
is that no point three minutes so then I
think is a bullet surpass see that
should be around a million so that one
says one point one okay it'll beat that
and he's saying it does Dana goes his
trend at 2.5 million what she's batshit
crazy okay that's just yeah for me it
does it sells that much like David 2.5
million I made the biggest paper I mean
for me like you know I mean cuz 2.5
million people by 5 million people watch
this show I'd be like that's nothing
it's in ratings let if we charge $70 -
it's a lot of money yeah yeah yeah 160
percent of Americans have $500 in the
back yeah and there's so many ways to
illegally stream it now yeah so I will
be buying it legally were you watching
it illegally we couldn't we Kenny we
could watch it with mr.
I suppose if you and I pulled strings
and said to Joe Rogan we want to go to
the fight I bet you could get a stick I
would not go that fight people keep
asking a baby enough I don't think I can
go to that no I wouldn't I don't I don't
want be around that wanna be home and
watching it I'd rather not what this is
how I'd rather not watch it then go to
it someone said dude the only we gonna
see if you see in person otherwise you
can't watch at home I like cool I'm not
watching I do not want to be around that
the crowd that's not my thing
yeah yeah can be good though that air
brother that's it all righty then
Brendan uh yeah I did few day threw him
back on the road dog's back dude the
road dog is by a date you got a date
crystal E&I mr. crystal E and I are
doing the Hong Kong in Oh
this Wednesday in Ventura we're doing
two shows this Wednesday at the Hong
Kong in yeah and how many people Gazette
see I'm gonna give you the link that
should selling 203 secondly if we there
there's about 400 tickets left
Oh honk I haven't sold any tickets seats
200 there's two shows how many days left
400 take it to left they it so get your
tickets immediately because they're
coming out where is the Hong Kong in I
got the Hong Kong is in Ventura County
and it's gonna be well it's gonna be me
and Chris D'Elia and tickets are at tea
fat K dot B P T and this is awkward
yeah B P T dot me is it all not okay
well this is the worst pitch of all time
either way there it is oh [ __ ]
hey look Rob Rios gonna be there though
supposed to be me and Brendan Schaub but
now it's me Chris D'Elia
Brent shopper Brian Cowen I'd only
actually probably call them and tell
them
alright this is not I'll be there this
Wednesday me and Chris we're [ __ ] off
social media their website sounds 17
yeah see you're good yeah nobody goes to
the Hong Kong in website so go see Brian
and Chris this Wednesday night my next
show
October 18th and 20th I'm in Salt Lake
City wise guys Utah those tickets almost
sold out after that be all things Comedy
Festival in Phoenix with Brian count
theof on big J and re just The Late Show
I think might be sold out there might be
a few tickets I'm not sure last thing I
heard it was like seven tickets left
after that San Francisco Cobb's
there's November 2nd and 3rd after that
I'm in Sacramento November 16th and 17th
and then just announced New Mexico New
Mexico December 7th and 8th two shows
Friday to show Saturday those are almost
sold out t fat K calm get your tickets
now that it be tip buddy hope dude do
not die at the Hong Kong in I won't I'll
try not to you and Island up doing that
pretty soon yeah for sure I thought I
was supposed to do it but then I decided
I had to cut my toenails alright this is
the finally kid we're out